so welcome everyone we're getting
started now yeah oh yeah hola seems that
everyone's been on time more or less so
welcome everyone to the conference part
of these PI data I hope that you will
enjoy that I hope that all the people
that was in the workshops yesterday also
enjoyed them themselves and the start we
have our keynote speaker it's a pleasure
to have Christine dodge here and he will
talk about the hitchhiker's guide to
sorry data size data science so lots of
data science to stop thank you and give
a plot and applause to Christine good
morning so this is a story story of The
Hitchhiker's Guide to data science so I
know if you know how the story begins
but for out Indian charted backwards of
unfashionable end of the Western Farrell
arm of the galaxy lies a small
unregarded Yellow Sun orbiting this at a
distance of approximately ninety eight
million miles is an utterly
insignificant little Bluegreen planet
whose eight descendant life-forms are so
amazingly primitive that they still
think digital Watchers a pretty good
idea this planet has or rather had a
problem which was this it had a lot of
theta and not enough data scientist so
that's why they wrote The Hitchhiker's
Guide to data science this guide has
already supplanted the great
encyclopedia Galactica understand the
repository of all knowledge and wisdom
let's introduce it before we start let's
explore the galaxy what does the galaxy
look like first of all we can separate
the galaxy in four different soul
Systems one is the set up the other one
is the exploration then the learn and
scale the setup is like when you decide
what development environment you're
going to use to do data science a lot of
people might have been using SAS or
MATLAB Python or etc and then you need
to decide what's going to be your
interface your ID whether you're going
to be using Jupiter notebooks pycharm
our studio matlab interface if you're
just going to use a text editor and run
things from from the command line the
exploration phase is when you start
asking questions to your data you ask
queries you transform your data and you
visualize it in learning we're going to
do machine learning deep learning is
when we start doing predictions grouping
clustering optum is at the end of the
day a lot of machine learning techniques
are based on statistics and optimization
and then we get to a point where a lot
of these tools have traditionally been
developed for single no single threaded
applications and then we have a problem
when we our data skills beyond that and
we have to learn how can we scale our
processes to manage those amounts of
data and there are different categories
that we can apply to like solve that
problem sometimes with compile assets
using parallelism using distributed file
systems or you know issue that come with
real-time processing so today we're
going to open the book of The
Hitchhiker's Guide of the galaxy and our
we're going to explore you know what's
going to be our setup how are we going
to explore and how are we going to scale
our our solution first of all I'm gonna
introduce anaconda and Jupiter anaconda
is a Python distribution with over 150
packages for data science it comes with
Conda which is a package and environment
manager that has several things that
make it really interesting for data
science applications one is language
agnostic and secondly is cross-platform
so all of this all of those who have had
pings installing Python on Windows have
finally have a solution for them
anacondas pretty large so if you want a
am in a fight version and be able to
manage your own environments you can
just install mini condo it just comes
with Python and Conda and manage your
own environments up through it anaconda
cloud is a web service that provides a
hosting for packages notebooks and
environments so it makes it very easy to
share with with each other and then this
condom vironment is are these like
custom some boxes that are easily tit
that provide a way to like reproduce
projects their science projects with
each other and bake making them
reproducible without all the complexity
that comes with things like darker or
virtual machines why why anaconda is
easy to install on all platforms it's
trusted by leaders in the industry Azure
machine learning use it as its back end
so if you're using Azure machine
learning from Microsoft they're just
running anaconda it has a large user
base over 3 million downloads it's BSD
license which means it's free for
commercial redistribution so if you
build something on top of anaconda like
Microsoft death you're free to like make
a profit out of it it's language
agnostic so far as we know data science
is not dead like a monogamous language
has as we have a combination of Python
our SQL Scala you can use condit to
manage packages in all those languages
and then allow this custom sandboxes
that makes it very easy to like share
with each other and reproduce your
results so that sign introduction what's
the newest thing that that's happening
in anaconda we have MKL optimization
navigator counter forge in our starting
from ferry release anaconda 2.5 it comes
with default MKL optimization library by
default which used to be a paid service
now it's free for all and
and improves performance roughly by
seven percent no x x 7 and it's
available by default and free for
everyone you can dislike conduct akhanda
and get delayed the 2.5 there's a newest
release that we bumped to 4.0 and that's
also going to have the MPL optimization
navigator navigator is a desktop
graphical interface because we're trying
to like bridge the gap between people
that have been using and doing analytics
for a long time using UI interfaces like
SAS and are not very familiar with the
command line up till now you pretty much
had to use the command light to you
install packages now we're trying to
like bring on board all those people who
have been using SAS Enterprise guide or
other UI commercial tools and are able
to like manage launch applications from
the applicate from this application
manage environments and also we have the
learning and community tabs with provide
videos from PI data conferences other
tutorials that are available online so
they can learn from those videos and
they get it directly and it's updated so
for previous people who might have known
anaconda launcher navigators substitute
it's a substitute for anaconda launcher
and it also integrates with an iconic
lab so if you have build packages and
you want to upload an or upload
notebooks that is also provided so Conda
has been a major effort at continuum
analytics the company I work for but now
it has been majorly adopted by the
community so it's not just continuum
analytics the ones building kind of
packages and providing them to the to
the open but there's also this community
called Conda fort which builds a little
bit builds Conda packages through a
different continuous continuous
integration systems and makes them
available directly uploaded in anaconda
Clouseau anyone can add that channel and
install packages that the community
maintains so if there's
it's that you want we get a lot of
requests you know it doesn't have to be
us you know our company building
packages for the community but the
community itself is adopting Conda as
the package manager for Python and
building packages himself we we've also
added support for our so there's an hour
channel in anaconda cloud we also bundle
a bunch of like the most essential our
packages for data science in a meta
package called our essentials so we've
you install our essentials you get about
80 packages in our for for data science
and then we also have added another
channel called mro which distributes
microsoft are open and that's also the
our distribution that comes with MPL
optimizations by default so Jupiter
Jupiter can be your interface to doing
data science and Jupiter is this web
application that allows you to create
kind of a report of what you're doing
because at the end of the day data
science is about storytelling a lot
about your like printing up doing you
know something and having a results back
having like data transformer or having
some predictions but you need to sell
those predictions to someone maybe in
your business to like buy into what your
model has done so providing our context
around what you've done is really
valuable and Jupiter allows you to do
that by not just writing code but by
adding explanation text by adding
interactive visualizations so what's new
in the Jupiter sphere two projects one
are the extensions and I'm going to talk
about Envy present and current
environment and another one also related
with the our support the ir colonel so
extension and we present so i bet you
all know that in jupiter notebooks you
can amp translate your notebook into a
slide deck that uses rebuilt a yes
what has typically happen is that you
didn't have a sim editor to edit the
presentation in a way the look maybe a
little more corporate so and be
presented at Jupiter extension that
bills editor in your Jupiter notebook as
a plug-in that you can activate and then
you enter it and have the ability to
edit slides layout and the things we
also have been developing a lot of other
extensions for some of our paid products
but makes those extensions open source
and we have a 2-1 it's called NB condor
colonel so that allows you to like from
the Jupiter interface select what kind
of environment what Python interpreter
or our interpreter you want to use in in
the notebook that you start and you can
also navigate and edit packages that are
included in those environments through
the Jupiter interface I are colonel so
jupiter has moved from just being up
ipython notebook centric so centered
around Python to using the same
interface with a variety of kernels one
of them is the ire kernel which has our
as its back in and you just made it very
easy with Conda in the archangel's
package so you can just can't install
our essentials and we start a Jupiter
notebook you'll find our as one of the
options to start a notebook and you see
that right here the notebook here it's
our so you can you no longer need any
like magic cells to run are you directly
can write are in a cell and get and get
rid of so no matter if your team is
using Python or your team is using our
or some of you are using are in Python
you can still tell you the same
interface to communicate let's move to
the second part exploration with pandas
and Boca
so pendas what what is pendants pendous
is this high-performance the package
that provides these data structures the
most common one is a data frame and has
a lot of methods around it that makes it
very easy to like transform your data
it's kind of like a building block it's
built on top of numpy and and it's very
widely used in the industry started in a
high-performance trading you know hedge
fund fine and so it really has evolved
from daddy now it's usually like
sciences data science and in other
fields so what's new so I don't know if
you've noticed but it has a new logo
there's a sticker with a new logo unlike
the gnome focus table for the stick
sticker madness people and some of like
the most recent changes there was a lot
of you know changing windows functions
two methods off integrating with with
x-ray which is a another Python library
for a rate computing labeler that makes
it very easy to work with label erase
something pretty big it has adopted the
ability to read sass files so in that
effort of trying to move people towards
the Python open source community from
commercial tools that is going to be
very well for people adopting an
industry where they're heavily using SAS
in their enterprise and being able to
read and integrate with people maybe in
your team who are using still that that
too and then something very neat that
came not in this last village but in a
couple ago is this like conditional
formatting on your data frames tables in
Jupiter notebooks so you can now you
know identify one different values or
may be negative or have like some
gradient of the value so you can really
identify when something you know when a
value is like too low or too big or
pocket them and also this one here on
having kind of this histogram built in
your your data frame so we have pandas
with pendant we've been able to like do
some transformations some queries but at
the end of the day we want to visualize
and we have matplotlib and other
relation libraries in the Python
ecosystem but bouquet really is
innovative in the sense that it makes it
very easy to build interactive data
visualizations without having to write
any JavaScript so no JavaScript you can
build kind of these three like
visualizations directly in Python and we
also have bindings in our scholar and
lua it's very easy to embed in web
applications so if you have a team and
the result of your data science project
it's a web application it's very easy to
put that visualization into it even
easier if you're using things maybe like
Django flat so it's all in the like
Python ecosystem and then server apps is
one you know you're not only having like
this static with some interactions in
the front end but actually calling back
on the server to run some computations
when you've move maybe's up a widget in
the front end in the client side so
what's new in boquete so we have boca
server arbor k and shining and then data
sheet her bouquet has had a server for a
while it's not like a new feature but in
January it was the 0-10 release there
was a new completely new rewritten
server back-end that uses tornado and
web socket and this allows you to do
things like for example this example
here what it does did like as when the
user selects an algorithm to apply into
your data set it goes to the back end it
runs like you learned on that model on
your data
and comes back with the results in the
front end so things like that where the
user can interact so imagined you know
building web applications that allows
you to like visualize different
algorithms with different variables
things like that we also have a new
improved gallery with some of those
examples of server server app examples
like the movie set review where you can
like look at different you know filter
by different values of movies by rating
or a year etc we also have improved a
lot the geo geo capabilities here we
have example of like different types of
tiles that are supported a lot of people
as well how about bouquet our hell does
that work is that like something that's
like a competition with I think
something like shiny and really it does
integrate well with with Chinese so we
have an example here that introducing
our studio you have UI interface that's
based on bouquet and then it gets
updates on the back end and just like
just random things but at the end the
back end is using shiny and the front
and is using bouquet so it's easy to
integrate as well so one of the most
recent projects in the bouquet in bulk a
land at continuum in this project called
data shader and data shader is this
graphics pipeline that allows you to
build meaningful representations of
large amounts of theta and even if it's
they're not large amounts it does
improve some of like visual issues that
we have with not that large of a data
set and we're going to see some some
examples so when we visualize data
there's some some issues that according
and it's it's more so when it the data
its larger but
is are not that many points and we
already see how the visualizations might
be misleading interpretation of what
what we see an example is what we call
over plotting so here we have two
distributions that have exactly the same
amount of points but depending on like
the order that the that you're going to
render those points you might have the
sense that one has more points than the
other one right so here we were seeing
that blue is more dominant and here red
and that's misleading because like they
actually both have the same amount of a
point another problem is like when
people try to fix this issue they try to
do saturation so with saturation it
improves a little bit but it's still
it's like a matter of number of how many
points overlap and with these parameters
right in this example here it just
really if 10 points overlap you're still
getting this misleading feeling so it
doesn't solve completely the problem and
it's very hard to trick the parameters
another point is like understanding when
you have large amounts of data people
tend to like sample to visualize but you
can see like how distinct the
visualization looks depending on how
your sampling how many points you get
and how many and how large the dots are
so to solve some of those problems or
all those problems we creation did this
visualization library called data sheet
and just like to visualize like what you
know that we traditionally do something
bad like that that this is common then
we see these visualizations all the time
this is actually a visualization of like
my first talk that I gave at a Python
conference and at PI data nope I Texas
two thousand thirteen or fourteen so we
can see here that you know and this was
a project I was working for the DARPA
which is like the US Defense Agency so
you can see what territory they were
interested in gathering tweets but
besides that
that's the only thing the the disability
she is telling me right where my
interest is but I'm not really able to
to tell you know how how is this like
how much distribution I have in like
turkey or like you know Saudi Arabia
India like because all this ploy points
overlap so that's the difference between
visualizing something you know that it's
just going to tell me you know select a
zone of interest while another
resolution that still is done with data
shader actually gives me a sense of
density and I end with this graphic
pipeline it's not just our density but I
cannot also ask interesting queries to
my data for example this one here is the
New York taxi data set and what we ask
is plotted blue if there are more
drop-offs and pickups and plot it red
it's the other way around so we can see
interesting patterns like you know that
the drop-offs are alike the site small
side streets well the pickups are in
like the larger vertical large street we
also can see all these like outliers
would be comes into the river right like
no one's going to pick you up in a cap
on in the middle of the river and then
this part here is also very interesting
this is the LaGuardia Airport and you
can see how the blue are very well
defined well the red ones are kind of
like messy and noisy and that's because
the pickups are underground so the GPS
signal is bad well that drop-off or in
like you know like without any
construction around it so the GPS site
signal is very good so just with this
visualization we can see things like
that we can also like see you know
central park and
and not just like we can all take a
sense of like density right and point
that are very you know our commonly pick
up zones drop-offs etc so i think i
mentioned it before here but data shader
use this in the back end to scale things
like desk and number and now we're going
to see some examples of where we're
going to talk about desk and number and
this one here i didn't mention but this
visualization here is about it's the
census data also in new york or the
manhattan is right here you can see
central park and if the census data and
its color by race so you can really see
race segregation in new york with just
this visualization and all of this is
Python and there are very few lines of
code all the notebooks are available in
anaconda cloud so you like download this
notebook and run get the data and run
and run them to get the same very cool
visualizations so now we've got to a
point where you know we're not working
anymore with data that fits that might
fit in memory which is kind of what has
been a problem with numpy and pandas
right and we want to scale that and
there's different degrees of scaling
right there's a point of data that fits
in your laptop but not fit in RAM and
you might also want to treat that and
computers and you know instances in
amazon get pre large so you could still
like do a lot of things with just the
other fits in you know in memory just by
getting bigger boxes if that's not the
case and you just want to use your your
laptop then you might have like 8 or
16gb pipes right so they said that are
larger than that you might need
you know you might think what what do i
do then and a lot of like people they
all that that's already big data you
should start using spark or whatever and
that's not true you can still do a lot
with multi-processing multithreading and
getting those results and that's why
what we did with desk is simplify the
user experience on using multi-threaded
multiprocessing schedulers by just
providing a numpy like and handouts like
api to the user and then you know it
gets paralyzed in the back end but you
don't feel you don't need to like worry
about all the issues that come with
pearl ism so that was a jesus an option
but so number number is a project also
that starry-eyed continue and it's
trying to like help you speed up your
applications that you write in pure
python and get speed upset or close to
performance of C C++ and Fortran and it
tests always providing a very easy
interface with just a decorator that's
called jit to get that function it also
supports CPU and GPU hardware so if you
want to take advantage of your GPU
number of the supports the compilation
for that and it integrates well with the
rest of the stack giving that a lot of
like the developers have also been you
know developers of other libraries in in
the in the stack so as I mentioned
before desk this parallel framework that
it's familiar because it implements the
api's of numpy and pandas it's very fast
for for numerical applications and with
benchmarked out with things like sport
and for array-like computations we can
perform 10 to 100 times faster in other
cluster clusters size scale not just
like single node with move to threaten
multiprocessing schedulers so basically
what desk is this collections that
be like a race which is like very like
similar to numpy erase the difference
very like to look pandas are your
friends back it's kind of like a JSON
like leave a structure for treating
things like text from returns from json
and then imperative it's just a way if
your you know your code does not fit
those data structures and you have some
custom code by using imperative you can
also build this graphs of tasks that
need to be executed automatically and
then when those crabs are created then
it when we have when we have different
types of schedulers the queen that we
can adapt depending on how large is our
problem so you know it might be that
just using a threaded or a
multiprocessing scheduler already like
fulfilled summer use because our data is
not as large as to use a distributed you
know cluster f computers if we do have
that requirement though we can use the
distributed scheduler and so what does
does it also has like very neat
visualizations for diagnostics and also
for monitoring the state of of your
computation and we can see for example
this one shows up like what's being
computed what's already done and what's
the next task that that is being
processed so what's new in the desk this
is very recent we just were just two
weeks ago we announced it at strada a
San Jose of the head of integration with
with task so now we can directly read
and build data frames and umpire race
from data that's on HDFS and also use
resources through yarn we all have like
fancy widgets that allow you to like
look you know how far away your
computation is so you don't like have a
sense of you know how long is it going
to take to finish which is also pre need
when you're running jobs in a
distributed environment and you don't
know if you have to wait an hour or 4 30
minutes or
you know you have to go to you know home
and come back the next day and see the
result it also has you know also you
this bouquet we try to use our own
project to improve so and this provides
that also a real-time interface to see
you know what its workers executing and
also what's your memory and CPU usage in
real time so you can monitor these
things so up till here this watch being
The Hitchhiker's Guide to data science
for today remember them the answer to
the universe don't forget your towel and
thank you very much this is my twitter
handle you can get the slides that Billy
pie later Mat 42
so we have some time for questions now
anyone
hello thank you for a talk I have a
question regarding tasks desk the one
things I don't understand very well is
how it deals with data sets bigger than
you can get into memory because I
understand that you get some by ilysm
and then you can use several calls or
machines but for example when I read the
documentation about our data frames I
get that kind of loads different parts
of the data and different the difference
but I don't know if it does it
sequentially or how it deals with it
because from the command it is not clear
now and I don't know what can I learn
more about how because if i use for
example spark i know that it gets some
parts of the data you can as you can
specify how many processes use and what
it does but in dusk I don't know what it
does okay yeah so this is like a very
fast intro but actually there's
different layers of desk the the first
one is like the let's let's call it high
level middle level and low level the
high level is in it's what we call the
imperative mode in which you have your
own code and you use and you just use it
to to build those custom graphs so
that's going to build that cross from
graph for you the the same middle ground
is just using it does just implement a
way to chunk numpy arrays and pandas are
in so it's just like the desk array and
the dash their frames are just like
chunked numpy arrays and then thats
knows how to put them together four
different operations and then the low
level is the part of that you can
actually define you the graph task by
just the graph description in Java
Python dictionary so you can actually
define the grass by itself without
needing to write you know custom code or
or using the default data structure but
building your own to build you know to
build something like this if that's what
you want it to do and then once you have
the graph what does you know so for a
long time
just builds that graph and then when you
want to execute it you call compute and
computers a wand where you tell what
scheduler you want to use and for each
scheduler you have different variables
that you can set like number of
processes you know number number of
workers etc the weight like the it's
going to depend so in the distributed
environment task is going to try to use
data locality to know what to execute
first we're so I like when you say
sequentially you want to make sure you
want to kind of put restrictions on what
gets executed is that your concern or
because you said like variables you want
to control variables like number of
threads or processes but then also the
sequence of when things get executed
policy know what what it has to load
first and later just to get something
doesn't fit into memory to be computed
because of course you cannot use
furthermore you have a threads and you
try to load 150 gigabytes of data you're
going to do it oh right well at same
time you want to do it one first part
and the second part right I guess it's
dawning in the car automatically so you
can define like the chunk like what you
define the tongue sighs and then you
have to define a chunk size that fits
any in memory that's kind of like the
you know that that's what current is
that you're not going to do something
like that so more questions I have one
it's kind of not question about how do
you get deed the geographical data the
maps I mean the matter New York was
amazing Oh lot on top of that oh well
that like there's like some of that
they're actually equitable this one here
yeah like this actually like the map
comes you can see the map because of the
data there's no there's no mat behind it
you just like see the contour based on
like the okay fine yeah I just a quick
question about that a shader you what
type of glyphs are supported right now
yeah so we saw Scott scatter plots and I
think we just added the we'll just
release this week version 02 so it's
still pretty new and we added support
for lines so time series data now we can
also plot we also have some examples
that show you know when you have a lot
of lines one on top of the other one you
also lose like density of the points so
now those two are the ones that we're
currently supporting and do you plan to
support more glyphs than those so we'll
have to check the roadmap I'm not sure
what I bet they're there are more what
would it also depends like what you know
if people start using it and they have
specific requirements then that's going
to help put it in the road map so if you
have any suggestions just open an issue
and we'll put it there yep we have time
maybe for one short question let's tank
racine thank you